in which quadrant is the point negative
seven comma seven located so let's just
review what a quadrant is a quadrant are
each of the four sections of the
coordinate plane and when we talk about
the sections we're talking about the
sections as divided by the coordinate
axes so this right here is the x-axis
and this up-down axis is the y-axis and
you can see it divides the coordinate
plane into four sections we call each of
these sections quadrants this one over
here where both the X values and the y
values are positive we call the first
quadrant and we use the Roman numeral
one then if we kind of move
counterclockwise around the coordinate
plane this quadrant where the X values
are negative and the Y values are
positive we call this the second
quadrant we call this the second I could
write it we call this the second
quadrant second quadrant then we go down
here where both the X values are
negative and the Y values are negative
we call this the third quadrant once
again using Roman numerals then finally
the quadrant where the X values are
positive but the Y values are negative
we call this the fourth quadrant so
let's see which quadrant the point
negative seven comma seven is located so
there's two ways to think about it you
could just say look we have a negative x
value our x value is negative so we're
going to move to the left so we're going
to be on this side we're going to be on
this side right here of the coordinate
plane so we're either just by the fact
that the x value is negative we're going
to be either in the second or the third
quadrant now we know that the Y value is
positive we know that the Y value is
positive so if the x value is negative
and the Y value is positive we're going
to land someplace right over here in the
second quadrant the other way to think
about it is you could literally just
plot this point and see that it falls in
the second quadrant so let's do that if
X is negative seven so that's negative
one negative two negative three negative
four negative five negative six negative
seven do I do that right one two three
four five six seven so this is X is
negative seven and then we have to go up
seven because Y is equal to positive
seven so one two three four five six
seven so the point negative seven comma
seven is right right over here clearly
lies in the second quadrant